[MUSIC]
The girls quietly climbed in the van.
Amy slammed the trunk close and
started the three day drive from
Washington DC back to the Mountain West.
She had done it, she had finally left him.
After five years of living in constant
fear that he might in some way hurt her or
her three girls, she had finally left him.
She thought about
the challenges that lay ahead.
There had been emotional and
psychological trauma for
her and her daughters Kira,
Jessie, and Gabby.
But it was worth it to be
able to raise her three girls
away from the addictions and abuse.
She had been to college,
but it had been four and
a half years since she had last had a job
and she never actually used her degree.
Amy qualified for
food stamps and Medicaid.
These government programs were
a lifeline but they were also a crutch.
To continue to qualify,
she had to stay in a low paying job.
There was nothing to help her
transition off of the government
assistance to a better life.
Amy was stuck.
Amy is not alone in her struggles
as a single mother in this country,
there are over 11 million single
parents in the United States.
Since over 80% of these
are single mothers,
my talk is going to focus
on their struggles.
Of course, everything that I
shared today applies to all
single parents, mothers and fathers.
So you're probably thinking Dave,
you're not a single parent.
Why are you talking about this?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Because Amy is my fiance.
We first met when we were 18 years old.
We then went our separate ways for
12 years.
During that time, he got into a bad
marriage and finally left four years ago.
Mutual friends brought us
back together two years ago.
Finally this last Christmas,
I asked Amy to marry me.
Because this relationship was
more than just her and me,
I wanted Kiera, Gabi, and
Jessie to be there for the proposal.
Then one at a time,
I got down on one knee,
put a little ring on each
of their fingers, and
asked them if I could be their dad.
They said yes!
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I am the luckiest man in the world
to have these amazing girls in my life.
Hearing about Amy's struggles
as a single mother has been so
frustrating because there's so
much that can be done.
For this talk, I'm going to share all
that I've learned about why single
mothers struggle to escape poverty and how
college and childcare assistance can help.
There are four key numbers you
should remember from this talk.
The first is 1 in 4.
One in four children in the United States
is raised by a single mother.
This is in large part due to
the growing trend of children being
born out of wedlock, divorce, and
abandonment due to substance abuse.
More than a third of single mother
households live in poverty.
For the second key number, $1.9 billion.
The government provides $1.9 billion in
food stumps every year to single mothers.
That's a market size that make
any eventual capitalist true.
These government programs do so
much to help these single
mother get back on their feet.
Unfortunately, even though they
are intended to be temporary,
there are no incentives to
help people get off of them.
So I've leaned college is critical to
help the single mothers escape poverty.
The Institute for
Women's Policy Research has done
a ton of research on single mothers.
They have shown single mothers
with a college degree,
get significantly better jobs,
make more money, and have better health.
And all these benefits trickle
down to their children as well.
Now for the third key number, $30,000.
$30,000 is the average net
gain the government can get if
they were to help a single
mother earn a bachelor's degree.
If the government ought to
provide childcare assistance,
financial aid, and
a case worker to the single mothers,
ultimately, they would come out ahead
in the additional tax benefits and
tax revenue from the higher paying job for
that single mother.
$30,000, and
that's not even considering all
the benefits that come to
the children of these single mothers.
The last piece of this
puzzle is childcare.
For a mother to be able
to go back to school,
she needs help raising her kids,
but childcare is expensive.
On average,
a single mother will spend a quarter
to a third of her income on childcare.
The government used to provide childcare
assistance to single mothers while they're
in college.
But during the welfare
reforms of the mid 90s,
the government stopped providing
childcare assistance to students.
Enrollment of single mothers
in college plummeted.
For those single mothers who have
access to childcare assistance,
their likelihood of
graduating on time triples.
Now for the final key number, 49%.
Only 49% of college campuses have
childcare centers on campus.
There's a government program that helps
support these child care centers, but
it's obviously not nearly large enough.
Now that I've shared these
startling statistics with you,
we need to act on this.
Let's think about the single
mothers in our life, and
make sure that they are welcomed
on every college campus.
Every college campus should have
a childcare center on campus.
Do you know if the GSB has childcare?
If not, ask the administration so
that they know you care.
On top of the GSB, Stanford has
childcare for both students and faculty.
For colleges that are so
concerned about diversity and inclusion,
by not making it possible for
single mothers to attend college,
they are missing out on this
key group of individuals.
As a side note, we as future business
leaders need to make sure it's
feasible for single mothers
to join us in the workplace.
Second, support the single
mothers in your life.
These amazing women have done so
much to raise children and
taking on the parenting
roles of two people.
Talk with them about those struggles and
ask how you can help.
Finally, there needs to be
a government policy change.
The government should provide
childcare assistance and
other support to every single
mother that's in college.
This financially and socially make sense.
So in conclusion, remember,
there are four key numbers,
1 in 4, $1.9 billion, $30,000, and 49%.
That 49% should be 100%.
So what's the rest of Amy's story?
Amy is getting her masters
in public administration and
is working for
a government city management office.
She didn't have access to
childcare through her college but
luckily her parents helped
her take care of her girls.
Amy wants to help undeserved single
mothers gain access to college and
a childcare.
She and
I are working on a non-profit to push for
these initiatives as well as push for
government policy change.
In her words,
I don't see this as a hand out but
as a hand up so that single mothers
are on an equal playing field.
Single mothers like Amy are raising
many of the future generation and
they deserve a fair chance.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]